un accord historique a été signé dans la
nuit entre la france insoumise et les
verts pour une nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale une centaine de
circonscriptions sont réservés aux
écolos qu'on est arrivé à faire avec
europe écologie c'est le fait de montrer
que finalement on n'était peut-être pas
si on désaccord que ça
non pas pour sur un projet sont les 20
ans à venir mais pour gouverner ensemble
c'est historique en tout cas nos
formations politiques n'avaient pas fait
d'accord aux élections législatives
c'est la première fois que ça arrive et
j'espère qu'il sera encore plus
historique demain peut-être si on arrive
à poursuivre l'élargissement que l'on
souhaite tous ensemble c'est pas
forcément d'accord histoire et pudique
que c'est exceptionnel en tout cas que
nous ayons réussi à nous mettre d'accord
pour ces législatives et que c'est aux
françaises et aux français d'en faire
peut-être un moment historique vous
annoncera pas un accord complet quoi les
latérales ou avec cinq parties prenantes
si on n'est pas d'accord sur tout et
qu'on n'a pas calé un majorité de choses
évidemment des détails pour ou encore
être calé mais voilà rassurez-vous là
j'espère
beaucoup de socialistes n'ont pas envie
de rester pieds et poings liés
durablement avec l'héritage de françois
hollande est une orientation politique
qui depuis quinze années en quelque
sorte les amis désormais sous la ligne
de flottaison c'est à l'accord pour les
législatives pour essayer de sauver des
circonscriptions qui ce qui reste une
pièce politique en rien c'est pour ça
que je pense que le ps tel qu'il est a
en tout cas avec cette direction est
mort je crois vraiment profondément à ce
que nous puissions réveiller ensemble un
espoir dans ce pays mais des conditions
à cela j'espère qu'aujourd'hui nous
arriverons nous aussi à parvenir à
conclure cet accord dans la journée dans
la soirée dans la nuit s'il le faut
jusqu'au bout y a pas de plan b il ya
qu' un plan assez celle de nous
rassembler on va quand même pas régler
tous les points en l'espace de quelques
heures alors que ça fait maintenant dix
ans qu'on ne se parlaient plus c'est
quand même tout ça est un grand pas donc
les choses les la main est tendue donc à
manon donc on va les lycées de nos têtes
prendre un café ensemble pour gérer leur
contrat mais vous nous dire mais négocie
pas non mais et on revenir on renie pas
où les attendait depuis des années la
volée des gens tout
ce qui attend les partis qui à mon avis
notamment le parti socialiste s'il
acceptait cette alliance est tout
simplement une disparition disparition à
la fois de leurs idées mais aussi une
disparition de leur parti politique
l humanité des gens sans jour dont on
prend les paris combien elle tient pas
50 députés et l'eire qui partent chez
makro jeu au pied un déchaînement de
violence contre une vingtaine d'en scène
notamment ce magasin bio investi par des
pilleurs entrés par effraction
on les voit sur ces images se servir
dans la caisse et les rayons du super
match sur le cortège les dégâts sont
innombrables
cette agence se dépouiller a perdu une
grande partie de ces dossiers
il ya eu 45 interpellations de ces
casseurs et notamment la personne la
femme qui a agressé le pompier qui n'est
pas blessé fort heureusement mais qui a
fait le tour des images de la télévision
guère à 38 ans et connu de la police
pour des violences elle se présente
comme une ancienne infirmière mobilisés
depuis les premières manifestations
contre le pass sanitaires les violences
parasites du 1er mai un visibilis la
marche des syndicats et servent la
propagande à nos pires adversaires
ras-le-bol le préfet de police avait un
capable de garantir le droit de
manifester en paix vous mettez votre
paquet de pièces dans la borde ça fait
un bruit de machine à sous à celle un
peu le jackpot et ça vous sort à un bon
d'achat que si nous mangeons est
aujourd'hui un pompier pyromane il
refuse à l'assemblée nationale les
moyens pour les policiers désarmés et
ensuite il doit se plaindre comme
n'avons pas pu intervenir on apprend par
exemple qu'il ya une dame qui est venu
et qui comme ça a pu avoir un bon
d'achat de 100 20 euros c'est pas mal ça
va alors